[Music]
everybody knows that elon musk
is really really huge about uh
constantly talking about world
population decline and how that's a huge
thing for the human race that's why it's
like you know his ethos for going to
mars he's tweeting recently mars
population zero you know i mean he's
congratulating people anybody's got a
big family or he's trying to work on
he's congratulating them he's probably
you know really just trying to put out
there that everybody should be making
children
and at the same time elon musk has
reportedly had twins with a neuro-link
executive and this news just
heard of this [ __ ] that's kind of crazy
like romantically or robotically maybe
more robotically if it's elon i need
more children yes i don't care if i'm
the father i just need more offspring
like that maybe
because i think elon [ __ ] dude i think
elon comes in a cup dude i feel like
he gets a ball gag on and grimes whips
them in the ass
hole okay he spreads his [ __ ] cheeks
and he she goes like on the bull's eye
oh my god he's got to be a freak yeah
dude he's [ __ ] on amber heard and all
this [ __ ] well during the case though i
heard he was quite the simple he was
simping out he was sipping so hard
you're the richest man in the world like
you should be simping right also i bet
amber heard you how to play him too
abrahart is [ __ ] nuts she's crazy not
if you're a true alpha dude if you're
true alpha you don't want to be sympathy
yo i bet you true
i bet amber heard took a [ __ ] on his bed
dude maybe i bet i bet she took a i bet
she took a [ __ ] in his testicles it was
just her love languages
she probably collected the stool sample
and [ __ ] made robots out of it i bet
she had a whole birthday cake before
a bunch of funfetti
[Laughter]
yeah
i feel like that's the trope like that's
the stereotype because yeah because you
because you're so big and powerful but
then really you just won't be hugged
yeah yeah
cause for me i'm like dude if i had
unlimited money the kind of games i
could play
imma send mariachi bands to you 24
[ __ ] seven
you're gonna walk down the street is
that romantic or is that scary that's
why you're my hero dude it's like the
games i'm playing is [ __ ] out of this
who would you send a mariachi band to
depends on what they're trying to do
like gio doesn't want to wash dishes no
more i'll have someone just throwing
glass dishes in front of her
for [ __ ] 24 hours a day
really good that's pretty funny do you
think mariachi band guys are watching
this one
can't wait to get that 24 hour game this
is about to get good
assuming that bart suddenly comes into
unlimited money though
yeah that's gonna be harder that'll be
harder i need to slide into the dms now
i need to be like hey bart i have a
mariachi band and i also sideline as a
dish crusher so yeah
just putting that here out there now so
um us the tesla spacex ceo and world's
richest man and boring company and
boarding company because lane throwers
and shitty symptoms with flamethrowers
come on dude he welcomed twins last year
with an executive at one of his other
companies near a link he's good at twins
what did he name him
uh like [ __ ] some angry pie i think
one in thing two a b he posted a tweet
uh saying usa birth rate has been below
min sustainable levels for 50 years and
pinned it to the top of his more than
100 million follower tick tock account
or twitter account let them immigrants
in that's how we handle it if you're
this rich though shouldn't you be having
twins with twins yes
only threesomes centerfold twins too yes
dude the hottest sisters ever and then
when you're [ __ ] have mirrors
everywhere so it looks like you're
[ __ ] 20 of them crazy dude but that
means you're also doing like hell of
yourself as well right but that's all
that matters
i'm the only one you see yourself in a
porno with 50 of the most beautiful
twins yeah which is a hundred or you
start getting here you start getting
overwhelmed because there's so much of
you that you're like wait i have a
question which one is me
who am i [ __ ] am i [ __ ] myself no
that's my ass
he's probably into that thing
yeah he's cloning himself so uh he
quietly fathers children with uh
somebody named siobhan zillis quietly
who works for musk at the company which
hopes to develop uh an implantable
computer chip for the human brain
the outlet obtained court filings
pertaining to changing the children's
legal names to incorporate the musk last
name and zilus as part of the middle
names and that's pretty much how the
information got leaked out
court findings for name changes i bet
she's a genius too huh
he's probably trying to make the super
genius so when he was courting her
instead of like taking her out to dates
she's probably like
good bone structure
all right
this is mother material you probably
press the button [ __ ] skander and
[ __ ]
yep what if like all these super genius
constantly breed and they just make
idiots like they just get dumber and
dumber
they might have a recessive somewhere in
there what if he's breeding just for
scientific research and trying to figure
[ __ ] out and he's using his kids as an
ultimate sacrifice that's better than
eating someone else's kids dude is that
how bad his branding is that we don't
think he's just a man sometimes yeah who
just wants to [ __ ] hard i think he's the
manager i guess so that makes sense got
nine kids but why would you actually
have kids
if you just want to [ __ ] hard why would
you have kids you just [ __ ] makes a
solid point actually like but maybe he
gets up maybe he gets off on on on he
gets off on knowing that the chicken's
gonna be the father
yeah yeah oh maybe that's his thing i
like that so he only gets the nine or
not even nine months because you really
don't really see the bump until like
second or third time maybe just the
thought of it i guess the idea yeah true
i only watched pregnant ladies [ __ ]
megan is too real
nicki's got the [ __ ] pregnancy like
even more real
hey man you brought it there hey i'm
fine with it i said it we're here now
[ __ ]
what'd she look like nicking a pregnant
suit no the girl
probably not as hot as amber her what if
she's hotter than she had to put the
twins in here
yeah dude you should have made a baby
with her that was like pre courtroom
lights amber heard too yeah like that
was like the heyday just throw her with
the [ __ ] aquaman
red hair constantly wet hair yeah she
probably
passed his [ __ ] robot test where he's
like you're a good mother well if he if
he couldn't figure her out that's that's
already the robot test is just the tat
on the head
say good skull size okay
obsessed
i love how everyone's reaction was like
oh [ __ ] well it's because it's because
of the billionaire thing dude we're
expecting she's pretty for a genius he
probably likes here
maybe she should give a good uh dome
i'm sure a lot of dome right there
sorry sorry i should have said neurodome
does she have the only problem
that's what's your fault maybe she's got
a neural link she does have slightly
crazy eyes though so maybe that's the
thing yeah she that's i think the bug
eyes are scaring me a little bit i think
he said that he's like hey yo nero link
dogs oh [ __ ] that's that's a good
pick-up line never leave these nuts hey
you working early
nuts that was his pickup line
why'd you have a bandana on it because
he's badass dogs
he's the alpha synth man even if you're
elon musk i don't think you should be
able to work that fool wears a bandana
like he's a dog on a hike he probably
like he's always got that he's got that
all like i don't know why maybe that's
that's like his yeah but why i don't
know if you use this as a babe to
[ __ ] no
[ __ ] tug on this [ __ ]
while they're on a hike
when he was pressed about or asked to
comment uh he he didn't respond about
his like secretly fathered twins but he
takes twitter
and kind of reiterates the idea by
tweeting
quote doing my best to help the
underpopulation crisis wait so i want to
go back a real real quick i want to go
back a little bit because you mentioned
he has nine [ __ ] kids i had no idea
there's a [ __ ] ton of kids i thought he
had the e equals nc square number six or
something
wait let me see if the eight
includes the twins so how many baby
mamas does he have
because to me he's just no different
than an athlete i know he's been married
five times he has two children with
claire boucher
or voucher i don't know better known as
a musician grimes five
uh and five a set of twins and a set of
triplets with his first wife and writer
justine musk so now and that was two
days ago uh in terms of when this was
written so now i'm guessing he has two
more children which makes it ten dude
wild five six seven eight nine nine i
don't expect it though because he really
does think that there's a problem with
they're just solving the problem
he's doing his part yeah but he could be
like jewish and just have 10 kids with
one wife he's not like leonardo dicaprio
though sitting on a private jet bitching
about the environment yeah
yeah we're the 25 year old hot [ __ ]
girlfriend this guy's on a yacht every
weekend this [ __ ] guy polluting the
ocean and [ __ ]
he is uh what is kind of cool is he's
improving child uh care uh help from
tesla and spacex and stuff because of
this yeah
i feel like that's a pretty billionaire
trope is you have multiple wives with
multiple children and it seems kind of
kingly
what
happens he's got the resources why not
[ __ ] it
many concubines many queens i just want
to know where the [ __ ] my cyber truck is
yeah yeah yeah put 100 bucks down two
years ago and have no updates talk that
[ __ ] to elon right now they haven't said
[ __ ] about it no they don't give anyone
no updates or they're making their doors
right now or they're not doing nothing
he's too busy trying to buy twitter and
[ __ ] let's see 2023 says cyberchuck will
deliver 2023. he's supposed to be 2401
there's support yeah he's too busy
busting nuts everywhere dude did any of
you guys put the hundred bucks down
because it's refundable it was
refundable i don't want a cyber truck uh
yeah i didn't want to look like a little
[ __ ] on the road again
are you gonna get it no why did you
[ __ ] reserve him
look at his [ __ ] truck outside yeah
he wants to get it
he's got all these toys on his truck
outside you know i'm a bitchboy truck i
don't know [ __ ] boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you